what's up reject nation today's video is
sponsored by
being a good person oh go out there
today and be a good person
how by doing good things
looking out for your fellow man we're
gonna watch this marvel maze
marvel major need to eat something today
need to stop filming without eating food
major marvel phase 4
update wanda vision falcon winter
soldier loki and black widow news a lot
of good
things that come let's check this out
yeah let's
check this out yeah check this out yeah
oh yeah subscribe
like button oh and turn on notifications
or even even
watch the rest of the videos do it get
your education from the reject nation oh
john john dude
i'm a poet and i wasn't even aware
oh you better beware when you're taking
a poop in your underwear
and you're going down to the fair you
got to be able to share
how much you really care about all the
times when i look into your eyes and
stare
you cannot deny that i got the devil
snare
what's going on it's good this is good
this is what the people came to this
marvel video
for we have lost our seminars of sanity
that's also a good reaction channel
let's do this
[Music]
how's it going everybody it's warren
welcome back to our channel
and today we have a ton of marvel news
specifically concerning phase four both
shows and
movies it looks like movie theaters
really quick we're probably going to do
a live stream for charity tomorrow if we
got to mention that i'm waiting to go to
the new computer i have some good news
for you in this video it looks like
disney and
marvel studios has given the green light
for production on all of the shows that
have been postponed so that's excellent
news as well
so i'll go over it all and i'll break
down everything that you need to know
be sure to subscribe so you can stay up
end game all you have to do is subscribe
like the video and leave a comment down
below
so to start it off real quick let's talk
about theater's opening back up
it's been reported by discussing film
that the national association
of theater owner representatives has
confirmed they expect
90 of the global theatrical market to be
open by july
17th this will be right in time for
christopher nolan's
tenant that is coming out now for those
of you who are waiting to go get inside
of a theater again this is really good
news
however of course there will most likely
be some social distancing guidelines
that come with the theater's real ten
people
and still has its original release date
it's widely expected that not many
new movies are going to come out in july
or august just
10. this is good news because black
widow is supposed to come out in
november and if movie theaters start
opening up in july
that means that movie theaters will be
open for four months before
black widow comes out in november
meaning that the release date probably
isn't moving and the black widow
november release date is very
very solid so it looks like we're really
not going to have to deal with any
release dates
moving back any longer and this is also
backed up by the fact that marvel
studios and disney are opening back up
again
in fact they're giving the green light
and beginning production again on all of
the shows and
movies that they were currently working
on before they had to shut down due to
the pandemic
they have begun to work on avatar again
in new zealand and it looks like
the falcon in the winter soldier one
division and the loki series are going
to begin production again
in july now again this is really good
news because
falcon and the winter soldier and one
division were supposed to come out
this year and they most likely are still
going to falcon and the winter soldier
only has about three weeks left of
filming and one division is in
post-production already
now there is some news of reshoots and
more filming that i'll talk about in
just a bit thanks starting production
again in july
there's plenty of time for both of these
series to finish everything that they
need for a
2020 release date on disney plus and
this all seems to be in full motion as
on tuesday the los angeles county task
force presented guidelines for immediate
reopening of
film and tv production and theme parks
so everything in hollywood
specifically at marvel studios and
disney seems to be getting back to
almost completely normal again obviously
there are guidelines that they'll have
to follow to be safe
but i don't think they've seen it
right now black widow in november of
2020 and then falcon and the winter
soldier and one division
this year as well so let's start off
with some news about the one division
series
although we've heard that filming has
been completed for the first season
exclusive series it looks like they're
going to start re-filming again
in july this could be two complete
scenes that they may not have shot
before or it could be for reshoots
but we do know that it is confirmed that
this is what they're doing
paul bettany who of course plays a
vision was planning on attending tampa
bay comic-con
but unfortunately he will not be
attending anymore he had to cancel and
according to his representative it's
because he had to go
back and do some more filming for one
division in july
now we pretty much thought that filming
had already been completed for the one
division series but the interesting part
is that they're going to resume filming
in la
and not atlanta where they begin filming
now they've been in post production for
a while now so this most likely means
they just need to reshoot a few scenes
to get right and again this is really
good news because it means that it's not
getting pushed back
right now it does seem like we're
getting it this year now before we dive
into the falcon and the winter soldier
loki and black widow news we have some
hawkeye and
young avengers news we haven't really
had too much happening in the hawkeye
world but today we have a production
grid for it
including when it's supposedly going to
begin filming
it says that the shoot date for the
hawkeye series is going to be on
september 28th
of 2020. filming in atlanta georgia
where marvel studios films most of their
shows and movies
and this shoot date is also seemingly
confirmed by charles murphy who put out
a tweet yesterday
stating that he has seen this shoot date
for the hawkeye series all the way back
in march
so this shoot date is supposedly very
legitimate but what's really interesting
is the plot summary that this gives the
project summary reads
clint barton aka hawkeye passes the
torch to kate
bishop bishop takes up the hawkeye
mantle after barton
she is also a member of the group known
as the young
avengers so we already knew that hakee
was going to pass on the mantle to kate
bishop but we didn't know exactly how
involved kate bishop was going to be
with the young avengers or what impact
the hawkeye series would have on the
young avengers however it looks like the
hawkeye series might actually be the
show
to start the formation of the young
avengers with kate bishop possibly being
the leader
kate bishop is going to get actual
training from justice
he's going to teach her how to beat him
is going to actually be transferred to
her and this is going to be very
different than most of the other young
avengers wiccan and speed will probably
have some training with their powers
if iron lad comes in he may have a
little bit of training with his powers
and the same thing goes for miss marvel
and then if cassie lane becomes stature
she may have
little to almost no training except for
watching her dad
from what we heard scott lang doesn't
want his daughter to go off and join the
young avengers so although
a lot of the young avengers might have a
little bit of training kate bishop is
going to be the only one who has been
trained by an actual avenger
intentionally
she'll be the only one actually trained
to be an actual avenger which will make
her a perfect candidate to be the leader
of the young avenger team
now there will obviously be some adult
in charge of this
perhaps spider-man or captain marvel but
with the exception of one of those two
it looks like kate bishop is going to be
the leader of the young avengers cool
and now we have news about the falcon
and the winter soldier series it's been
reported that they're going to resume
filming in july just like wanda vision
now we recently heard some pretty
interesting news about the series
charles murphy from
murphysmultiverse.com has reported that
if they're going to do a second season
of the falcon in the winter soldier
they'll have to retitle the series
now that implies that bucky or sam are
going to lose their title of the falcon
or winter soldier
which implies that one of them most
likely sam
is going to go on to become the true
captain america in the first season
now this is expected even though most of
us thought sam was just going to go into
the series
already being captain america since
steve rogers gave him the shield at the
end of avengers end game but of course
we know that u.s agent john walker is
going to be captain america
at first but based off of this report
that season two would have to be
retitled it looks like sam will go on to
become captain america which is why
you will have to be titled something
like captain america and the winter
soldier
people who were worried that we'd never
see sam as captain america
it looks like we don't have to worry any
longer and along with one division
and falcon and the winter soldier the
loki series looks like it's going to
pick back up in july as well
now loki still seems to be on track
however we have a very interesting
report by
atlanta filming they reported the other
day that if falcon and the winter
soldier airs in august it will happen
episodes but loki they might be able to
split up
which would be weird since it's a
multiple season story already
this is implying that the loki series is
going to be a very very big deal
more than one season has already been
confirmed and now this report makes it
look like that the shows might actually
be stretched out into two-part episodes
now they do go on to say that nobody
really knows and they'll know more next
week but it sounds like they've done
quite a bit of filming already don't
have a lot to cut out and have more
filming to do as well
and again this implies that this story
is going to have a big impact on you and
that's most likely due to the fact that
cam
is most likely going to make his debut
series
king will most likely go on to become
the mcu's next major villain and most
likely the avengers 5 villain as well
and since his story is going to be tied
into the loki series it would make sense
that they can't exactly cut a lot of
scenes out of the show so that's really
exciting but more details on that
next week and to top it all off black
widow news it's looking like we're going
to be seeing a lot more of
young natasha romanoff in the blackwidow
movie than we thought
the marvel fandom has discovered an
actress by the name of anechka her
instagram does not have that many
followers however she is followed by
marvel studios go follow her next
fact we did hear rumors that marvel
studios was looking for actresses to
play a young natasha
this was for flashbacks of her childhood
well there's quite a bit of evidence
that this girl is going to be playing a
young natasha if you go to her instagram
page
her very first photo of her is of her in
budapest and she has
red hair she was most likely there
filming for the black widow film her
hair is most likely red because she's
playing a young natasha
and why else would the official
instagram page of marvel studios be
following her so for those of you
wanting to learn more about natasha's
just in the past few days it looks like
everything is getting back on track and
hopefully
not too long from now in a few months
we're going to get the first projects of
phase
four so let me know what you are most
excited about
don't forget to like this video and
subscribe so you can stay up to date on
everything happening in the mcu for live
updates you can follow me on twitter and
as always thank you all so much for
watching
woof woof out meow wow
thanks you're a good guy warren love you
guys
love you big fan of yours sorry guys i'm
just following in netca right now
on social media oh i know how to do this
is we go to marvel studios page
you gotta find her handle though because
her handle is like
on i found her i found her i found her
yeah yeah there we go oh she's shut up
and followers following
following anecha here we go we should
message her you playing
playing black widow what's up what'd it
do
can we get an interview so the main
thing that's going on is that 90
of theaters are expected to reopen uh in
july
in correlation with uh you know tenant
we don't know what the
yeah i thought by now we could get leave
if ninety percent june
yeah we should get at least an update on
like well how how are they going to do
that it's almost a month away because
there's two sides of me that are
thinking about
why they're going to be able to do this
one is
what everyone's talking about like
social distancing having to wear masks
when you're going to the theaters and
stuff
which just between plexiglass which just
seems right there's all these protests
happening in the world right now which
are which are necessary protests i'm
going to say this right now
vast majority of protesters are not
looters or people
doing violent acts okay vast majority
i stand by the peaceful protest 100 okay
i participated in one myself with that
in mind
one part of me is thinking with the
protest happening what's the situation
with kova 19 are the cases rising
it seems likely that it would
unfortunately when i participated in a
protest i did manage to keep a distance
and everyone was wearing master that was
great i can't see that but
inevitably like there's there's going to
be people where yeah people are in a
crowd it's going to happen yeah exactly
the be all end all of protection with
the coveted cases most likely rising i
honestly haven't been following the
information on that
uh as strongly as i have been following
on the situation with the protest the
other side of me is going
well maybe movie theater owners are
going
seems like people are comfortable to go
out let's open the theaters
you know afraid of and and you know for
multiple reasons too because obviously
it's worth paying attention to what's
happening out in the streets of the
world right now but
also you know i'm a little wary that
yeah it's gonna
sweep that coverage away and it was
already controversial coverage getting
people to agree on
covett in the first place yeah so yeah
there was a part of me during this that
was like oh god are we already
forgetting and just going like oh yeah
people are back outside you know they're
protesting and they're at bars
so we can open back up and i know amc is
afraid of shutting down
entirely and stuff that's like the main
news tapes you're just like
they're probably not going to be like in
business literally every amc story is
like cut to amc headquarters
everything's on fire
people are running around screaming i
can sympathize with that for sure but
it just here on june 5th when we're
shooting this
it seems still like it's too soon to go
yeah that'll definitely happen on the
17th of july with no incidents
i still think we'll have to wait and see
i know that's the current report right
now but
with the protest going on if that
happens to start calming down by july
or uh lessening and number like we we
don't know what's gonna like we
this we have no idea what this this
whole year has been uncharted territory
you know part of me is like let's keep
the theaters closed for a while so the
outside world is just for doing the
right thing or going to get your
groceries
yeah we'll have to wait and see here's
hoping
sure with them continuing production i'm
sure they have a lot edited already so
they'll probably be doing with
falcon and winter soldier and wanda
vision they'll be
shooting for whatever like to wrap up
the edits
you know yeah i mean you've got to
imagine that probably falcon and winter
soldier hopefully has gotten a chance to
get ahead on some post and then they'll
go back and have a good idea now of all
the extra footage they need to compile
and then yeah one division has to be
just putting the finishing touches on
now and so i would imagine that anything
with the tv shows and the schedules
mostly would have to do with just
what proximity they need to be in yeah
you know bottom line the big
plan the tv news uh is the most solid to
me
opening up film sets i think is a decent
step you can keep those i feel like you
can get those under control maybe it'll
take a little longer
yeah and they're probably going to be
having people on set
who are there too because you can you
can have people come to your home to
test you for covid now i think in l.a
it's like in total two to three hundred
dollars somewhere there so i imagine
they're probably going to have someone
on set who
who's going to be testing people and
they'll daily
yeah and just have the department spread
out and you know all that stuff
exactly story stuff that was covered
there's a whole lot of news here
this is like a little magazine uh
the idea of kang appearing in the loki
series
i'm hoping that people who are who don't
really care about the tv shows
are following some movie news and social
media stuff the more
we hear about like especially with one
division and tying into doctor strange
and
multiverses and all that and then now
hearing that potentially the big
baddie of the next giant avengers climax
movie could be kang
and being first introduced in the loki
show it's like guys
we have to be watching the show so yeah
it's a must
watch now in order to keep following the
proper timeline well that's what's
fascinating
about watching marvel do their shows now
as i feel like looking
back we have all these examples of them
you know through
other or in conjunction with other
studios sketching this out because i
also you know thinking of the
hawkeye news and the um kate bishop news
they've probably kind of tested this out
with stuff like the runaways
with uh cloak and dagger and now they're
going to do their own version of that
with the young avengers and i feel like
now that they are explicitly going these
are all connected they're going to make
sure we know
yeah one way or another yeah there's
going to be in the movies
i imagine there's going to be like
post-credit scenes like
whenever they had text like thanos will
return or something
they're gonna say something like loki
will appear in disney pleasure like
they're gonna
they're gonna have to specify you gotta
go to disney plus
and you can bet maybe they'll have like
a new bumper that has
footage from the tv shows and people go
where's that footage and then they gotta
look it up and then they'll find it
it's just funny because the shows before
the netflix shows agency shield were all
connected
um and but it's like before the shows
were like please
please let us be important please
acknowledge us
please please please acknowledge us
movies people care
right and now when the movies are going
to be like you you please
watch the shows we made these for you
you never have to stop watching marvel
content if you don't want it
and then her being uh potentially like
the leader of young adventurers
kate bishop the big thing with like
jeremy renner and hawkeye
he never got his due until like end game
you know and gabe was like hey this is
my favorite one of hawkeye
right even then he got dogged by that
haircut fair enough yeah and jeremy
renner i
i believe has been vocal in the past i
i'm under the
belief that he has been vocal in the
past about how he didn't really get the
screen time or the character treatment
that he
really believed he was going to get when
he signed up for all this and imagine he
doesn't mind handing off the hawkeye
mantle
um at the same time although you know
he's got a nasty divorce
well he can hang around as you know like
a wise father figure
character fat father this could be their
chance to reinvent hawkeye and make the
hawkeye character a lot more of his
significant leadership piece and uh
anecha go follow her on instagram guys
like subscribe to a netcast watch your
story a surprise there's gonna be
flashbacks hell yeah
at least it will be a real actress
instead of a d.a yeah we'll get a dh of
william hurt
yeah all right guys well what do you
think of this news what are you most
excited for
theaters reopen in july you definitely
going but this could all
i mean honestly theaters could stick to
this and if people don't go
then all the plans change again like if
people do not show up for tenant
like this is a marvel video and and like
any news about theaters are all linking
back to tenants so people
don't show and not if enough people show
up for that 200 million dollar film
so i'm worried for christopher nolan
because right now it seems like the
entire film industry is on his back
so they are yeah or at least the
exhibition film industry guys subscribe
to cosmic wonder click that notification
bell notified when we got a video up
last but not least
patron of the day shout out
eric horseman my dude thank you so much
for being here man
talked recently you got your coveted
test came back
negative which i'm always happy to hear
about and it's also pride month
wanted to shout you out my happy sensual
gay
brother how you doing buddy i know right
now while we're celebrating prime month
i also know that you're
actively going out there participating
in peaceful protests so thank you so
much
for doing all these acts of love being a
great human being
and then of course showing your support
to us as well you have been an absolute
treasure in our lives
thank you so much and i hope this month
amidst all the
heavy stir of emotions that you could
also celebrate some things to be
prideful about love you buddy